hi everybody I am dr. simi Osmond I'm an
expert in epidemics a spread of disease
and the spread of misinformation about
disease over the next few weeks I'll be
responding directly to your questions as
you send them to me but right now what I
want to do is go through the 50 most
googled questions about corona virus
asked this week starting from 50 and
working down to one question 50 will
corona virus mutate so right off the bat
we're talking about the new corona virus
it's real name is Tsarskoe v2 and it's
part of this family of viruses called
corona viruses and yes like every virus
this novel coronavirus does mutate even
though it has mutated it doesn't seem to
have mutated in a way that makes any
meaningful difference to the way it
spreads or causes disease in humans are
symptoms sudden so they could be sudden
onset but we see that more with the
influenza virus it looks like with kovat
19 symptoms can be more gradual does
corona virus affect animals so yes it
can and it looks like this corona virus
may have originated in a bat gone to
another animal and then arrived in
humans does corona virus kill healthy
people yes it can and that's why we're
making this point about social
distancing the higher death rates are in
older people and in people with
pre-existing conditions and a suppressed
immune system can I get infected with
the new corona virus if I'm wearing a
mask yes
but it does greatly reduce your chance
of getting infected the point here
though is that because we have this
massive shortage of masks we're
encouraging people not to wear them
unless they really need them meaning
they have symptoms or they're near
somebody who has symptoms because we
want to conserve as many masks as
possible for our first responders and
healthcare workers when will a vaccine
come right now we're seeing the
beginnings of phase 1 clinical trials
and the phase one is where you're
testing it only in healthy volunteers
and a very small group of them from that
point it's then at least 18 months if
not many years before you have a vaccine
that both works and can be scaled up do
coronavirus symptoms come and go from
the time somebody gets infected it takes
on average about five days for them to
show symptoms but it could be as early
as two days or as long as 40
in days once somebody is sick it can be
anywhere from around 2 to 6 weeks that
they continue to have these symptoms why
is it named coronavirus when you look at
it under an electron microscope you see
this the virus is studded with these
spike proteins and they give it the
appearance of having a halo or a crown
and Corona happens to be the Latin word
for crown did coronavirus slow down in
China yes the virus seems to have
reached a peak on the epidemic curve and
in cases started to decline when was
corona virus discovered so it was back
in December around December 26th at a
Chinese physician noticed an unusual
pneumonia and then it was on January 7th
that the new virus was identified will
coronavirus go away in the summer it's
unlikely and especially here in the
state will corona virus affect the stock
market yes we've already seen that
happen why is corona virus called novel
novel just means new has corona virus
been around before that family of corona
viruses has been around for a very long
time four of them are what caused the
common cold in US but this particular
one Tsarskoe v2 is brand new does
coronavirus need isolation when somebody
has symptoms we know they're contagious
we want to keep them away from others to
prevent the spread of disease what are
corona virus symptoms it causes fever
cough shortness of breath and it can
cause very severe pneumonias and
potentially even death more corona virus
go away probably not totally look at
what happened with h1n1 flu in 2009 it
caused a pandemic that year and now it's
a commonly circulating flu it's likely
we'll see the same thing with this novel
coronavirus did corona virus come from
snakes highly unlikely why did the
corona virus start in China China's a
country of more than 1.3 billion people
the chances of something starting there
are just higher than starting in a
smaller country and increasingly all of
us humans are living in closer proximity
to animals so this happened in China but
it could have happened in many places
can corona virus spread through water so
no there's no evidence right now that
the virus can spread through water we'll
coronavirus end the world No let's all
take a collective deep breath I know you
have like the end of the
but it isn't is coronavirus in Mexico
yes it has spread there can coronavirus
spread through close yes it looks like
the virus can survive on fabrics which
coronavirus is in China I think this
question is asking about the new corona
virus called Tsarskoe v2 can the corona
virus be stopped yes it can eventually
with isolating people who are sick
practicing social distancing while the
pandemic is at its peak and also
developing antiviral treatments and
vaccines can the corona virus to live on
surfaces yes we think it can survive on
surfaces anywhere from a few hours to a
few days but it depends on the exact
type of surface and on the environmental
conditions was corona virus engineered
no it wasn't where is the corona virus
in the u.s. it's been detected in all 50
states kam corona virus spread through
food so right now there's only evidence
of this in virus spreading from one
person to another there isn't evidence
of people contracting the infection from
touching a contaminated surface but
that's theoretically possible and that
could include food as well can corona
virus spread through mail now that we
know it can potentially survive from a
few hours to a few days on a variety of
surfaces it is a possibility that mail
could be contaminated
why is corona virus deadly it's deadly
because it attaches to receptors on the
surface of our cells in our lungs and
our respiratory tract and it can cause a
very severe pneumonia that then causes a
lung failure and then we can also see
multi organ dysfunction as well did the
new corona virus come from bats what we
think at the moment is that this new
virus came to us from bats who infected
an intermediate animal and then that
animal may have infected humans why is
the new corona virus dangerous it's
dangerous because it causes a
respiratory tract infection it's also
dangerous because this is the first time
humans have been exposed to this virus
and it means we have no pre-existing
immunity to it how did the new corona
virus spread in China so as I mentioned
we think that this new virus originated
in bat this corona virus worse than the
flu I'm getting asked this question so
much I think people are wondering well
flu kills tens of thousands of Americans
every year why are we so worried about
this new virus here's why I'm worried
it looks like the death rate from the
new coronavirus is at least ten times
higher than the death rate from seasonal
flu does coronavirus go away so I
already answered that house cried a
virus reached India yes sadly it has
I've been seeing cases they're reported
since the end of January is coronavirus
a pandemic
yes it's corona virus new yes can corona
virus in dogs spread to humans there's
one case of a dog infected with this new
corona virus it didn't show any signs of
disease and there's no evidence of
transmission from a dog to a human how
does corona virus work the virus enters
the respiratory tract through the nose
the eyes or the mouth and then it takes
over our cells own machinery to its own
ends to make more copies of the virus is
on God it's corona virus man-made no it
is not
it's corona virus in the u.s. yes it is
definitely here can coronavirus be
treated sadly there's no specific
antiviral treatment just for this corona
virus but what we do as doctors is treat
the symptoms is corona virus fatal yes
sadly this new corona virus can cause
death particularly in people who are
older have a compromised immune system
or have a pre-existing health condition
such as diabetes high blood pressure
heart disease things like that
it's corona virus curable no we don't
have a specific treatment for this new
corona virus is corona virus airborne
this one is so tricky because there's no
Universal definition of exactly what
airborne means when a person who's
infected with the new corona virus
coughs or sneezes they disperse droplets
from their respiratory tract and those
droplets can be full of virus they're
said to travel about 3 to 6 feet now
compare that to somebody who has measles
and sneezes the virus then clings to
particles that hang in the air those are
much smaller particles compared to
droplets they can travel further and
they can just stay suspended in the air
for a lot longer now I will say but this
is a new virus right now what we're
saying is that there's a droplet
transmission we're not calling it
airborne
how did corona virus
star so this new coronavirus as I've
mentioned a few times probably
originated in bats went from bats to an
intermediate host to some other animal
and then from that animal to humans
how does corona virus spread so like I
just mentioned with those droplets what
we understand is that an infected person
coughs or sneezes and those virus and
Laden droplets can land on another
person make their way into the person's
respiratory tract and that's how it
spreads it could also spread through
inanimate surfaces maybe an elevator
button or a door handle but that's still
being studied right now the evidence is
a person-to-person spread is coronavirus
deadly that's a number-one question and
the answer is yes worldwide this new
corona virus has killed more than 6,000
people as of March 17th 2020 so those
are the most googled questions as of
this week I do think there's a lot of
power in information and a lot of
comfort in dialogue so if you have any
questions at all please put them here in
the comments reach me on social media
and I'll be back here in the wire
channel responding to your questions and
concerns
[Music]